this Saturday the 16th we're going to
have an open planting day at the carp
with food first
so come on down to Cass and meadow
streets right on the corner opposite Sam
Bartholomew's Church
please bring along your boots your
gloves your shovel and of course bring
your picnic along we've got lots of
heritage fruit trees we've got lots of
shout about that we need planted we've
got lots of mulch and compost that we
need to move around so what's also
exciting is that a lot of people are
bringing their own trees as well and
either a family is bringing a tree which
they want to plant as their tree and
they've been donated a lot of other
plants like rhubarb as well and it's a
great community project which we're
really looking forward to this is the
first food forest in the waymaker area
and really we want people to be involved
we want the community come together and
get involved in this Legacy Project so
please come on down the starting time is
10 o'clock that's what time we're going
to be opening the gates we're going to
have a blessing at 10:30 and then we're
going to plant those trees move the
mulch and move the compost and then as I
said we're going to have a picnic